the north part of the valley has seen a
lot of growth in the last couple of
years for sure while housing
developments and warehouses boom near
the northern beltway the lake mead
boulevard and civic center area also
changing as well 8 news now reporter
sally jadamillo says despite the
pandemic the area continues to bring
more positive growth
i think years ago when we asked our
residents what is it that we wanted to
see one thing that was identified were
sit down restaurants north las vegas
councilman isaac barron represents ward
one it's a vast area from tropical and
lamb down to lake mead and pickles and
baron is especially proud of the work
they are doing along lake mead boulevard
i think this is one of the places to be
in the valley
new businesses such as denny's and
dunkin donuts are adding to the list and
businesses in this area tell me they
want to bring better services and good
quality to this north las vegas
community i think that bringing
a nice safe place where people can come
in sit down enjoy their coffee i think
that just brings more value and more
positivity to the neighborhood eva
vieira is the owner of the north las
vegas dunkin donuts and says change
starts with more visibility our sales
are growing daily and it's incredible
erwin arroyo's the owner of vegas bakery
he along with cali bomb burgers were
among the first eating establishments in
the area and tell me business is good
for them actually all the restaurant
around is helping us a lot and we are
pretty happy with that the plan
is to create a downtown walkable
community one that reflects the
community but also placed with strength
saliharmiyo live local now